believe it or not 37 years separate
david lynch's 1984 dune and denis
villeneuve's 2021 reboot that's like two
timothy chalamets but as someone who's
just spent the last few weeks studying
up on dune watching both the 1984
version and the mini series sequel
starring james mcavoy and susan sarandon
i thought it would be fun to take a deep
dive at some of these major differences
and let me tell you there are spicy
changes that could have a huge impact on
dune part 2. but before we begin let me
use the voice to ensure you like and
subscribe because i have more dune
videos on the way perhaps the most
obvious difference is that dune 2021 is
split into two parts the 1984 version
tells the entirety of the doom novel in
its three hour run time while part one
only makes it to about two thirds of the
way into the story and if you don't
wanna know what happens to paul in the
second half consider this your spoiler
warning the history and politics of dune
can be a lot to take in for one not
familiar with the dune universe and the
84 version spends a whopping 10 minutes
giving the viewer a crash course in dune
lore whereas villeneuve basically drops
you right into the story and gives you
only as much information as needed you
hear some cheney at the beginning but
other than that it's few and far between
in 1984 at least a half dozen characters
have voice over plus a narrator who
guides the viewer along and for the
record i'll be using the frank herbert
pronunciations of these names because
they can be different in both films
doon's story really begins when emperor
shaddaam who we never see in vilnius
version but plays a large role in
lynches takes control of arrakis away
from house harkenin and gives it to
house atreides if you're a bit lost of
how all these houses work in relation to
the emperor check out my dune 1984
ending explain video one of the first
scenes in lynch's version is the emperor
and spacing guild conspiring against
house atreides a scene that we never see
in vilnews in fact we don't see the
guild navigator at all and the spacing
guild is only mentioned once the emperor
fears house atreides is becoming too
strong duke lado has become increasingly
popular among the houses of the landsrod
and he believes them to be developing a
new weapon that incorporates sound
something that isn't brought up in this
new version fearing his power could be
in jeopardy the emperor joins forces
with vladimir harkenin to lure the
atreides into a trap with arrakis as the
bait in both versions paula tradies has
dreams however in vil news there's a lot
more of them and they're even more
cryptic i'm planning on coming out with
a dune 2021 ending explained soon which
will go over this in more detail the
atreides home planet of kaladin is
explored more openly in 2021 with
sweeping exterior vistas villeneuve also
spends more time developing the
relationships between paul and his
parents something that is brushed aside
rather quickly in 84. and this time
spent on character development really
helps round out the characters who come
across as rather flat in the older
version not mentioned in 84 is paul's
grandfather we see a painting of him
along with matador paraphenalia as seen
not in 1984 is duke lato atreides
accepting control of arrakis by the
herald of the change this also
establishes the atreides family signet
ring which gets passed down to paul and
later to paul's son lado the second we
also get our first look at reverend
mother helen moyim of the bened jesuit
basically these johnny sins looking
women however we never see them without
their head pieces off to determine if
they're bald like in 1984. perhaps one
of the biggest differences is the
absolute glow-up of duncan idaho whose
part is drastically expanded in vilnius
the 1984 version he's in about two
scenes and has little to no interaction
with paul villeneuve takes the time to
craft a friendship between paul and
duncan even foreshadowing duncan's death
when paul says he foresaw it in one of
his dreams villeneuve decides to have
this paul and lado bonding scene outside
the graves of their ancestors whereas in
lynch's version it's overlooking the
ocean both versions have paul training
however you can see the difference 37
years of improvement in visual effects
have had regardless the effect is still
the same with these shields they have
the ability to soften incoming blows
unfortunately we don't get a scene where
paul fights a robot or patrick stewart's
gurney runs into battle holding a pug
yeah that actually happens welcome to
the homeworld of house harkonnen gady
prime and i absolutely love what they
did with baron vladimir harkin in here
in the 84 version he's just so over the
top both in look and mannerisms whereas
skarsgard here plays him more subdued
and restrained the color scheme is also
markedly different with 84s being green
and sickly and villeneuve's dark and
grim we're then introduced to dave
bautista's beast robin vladimir's nephew
i guess i should mention all the
harkening and villeneuve's version are
pale and bald while in lynches he goes
for soulless gingers
i have a soul surprisingly missing from
2021 is fade ralph harkin vladimir's
other nephew who was played by sting in
1984. no word yet if he was cut entirely
or will make an appearance in part two
we also get a look at piter looking very
different than his 1984 counterpart
notice the lack of staining around his
lips which was due to consumption of
sappho juice used to amplify a mentats
mental powers this seems to be replaced
by this black mark under his lips which
the atreides mentat luffy or hawat has
as well you may also notice their eyes
roll to the back of their heads when
accessing information that's because
these mentats are like human
supercomputers computers and ai haven't
really been trusted in the dune universe
since humanity was previously enslaved
by ai and it wasn't until the great
revolt that they were freed something
not mentioned in 2021 before heading to
arrakis lady jessica and lado make love
this is where alia is conceived paul's
future sister we get a brief glimpse of
her in one of paul's dreams in 2021 but
this love scene is omitted we'll see a
kid version of alia in 1984. vilnews
version also places more emphasis on the
fremen locals we see how they're quite
religious and chant listen al gabe
basically the freman word for off-world
prophet paul spends much of his time
studying arrakis but the 84 version has
no mention of the sand walk away the
framing walk to avoid alerting sand
worms in both versions we see an
assassination attempt against paul using
a hunter seeker we never find out who
was responsible for this in the 1984
version but in 2021 we learned a
harkonnen had been living in the walls
for six weeks biding his time this pet
never seen nor this scene between the
baron piper and the reverend mother she
wants to ensure that in the impending
attack that paul and jessica aren't
killed lady jessica is benedescerate
after all thus the reverend mother
believes she has some authority over
what happens to her but the baron finds
a loophole around this he won't kill
paul and jessica he'll just drop them
off in the middle of the desert and let
the blistering sands take them another
big difference is kynes who in the 84
version was played by max fonseido she
is the overseer of change helping
facilitate the transfer of power between
harkonnen and atreides and acting as
sort of a diplomat between the atreides
and the emperor we also get our first
introduction of stilgar one of the
fremen tribe leaders in the 84 version
he never visits duke lado nor do we get
that awesome spinning scene the 2021
version also places more emphasis on
frem and tech like the paracompass
duncan gives paul or the moisture tent
jessica and paul used to survive in the
desert the villeneuve version makes use
of these ornithopters and this is what
they use to get around in lynch's
version this whole spice harvester
rescue scene is different as well
vilnu's version is much more tense
having both paul and lato get out of
their copter to help save these stranded
men in lynches you basically just have
lato yelling at the men to move and when
paul ingests some of the spikes he
experiences more visions and hears the
words quitsat's hararak an old shaksoba
term to describe the chosen one although
he does smell the spikes in lynches he
doesn't have any of those visions here
we also get our first look at a sand
worm lynch's sand worms have these
mouths that part three ways well vilnius
are purely circular the teeth are also
markedly larger in the 1984 version we
never travel to seleucid secundus where
the imperial army fleet is kept we do
however see planet chitin where the
emperor lives if you've seen the
mini-series children of dune seleucid
secundus is featured there blood from
these poor souls are covered on the
sardakar the emperor's elite soldiers
who look quite different from their 1984
counterparts the betrayal of dr yui also
plays out a little different than in
1984. in vilnius he gives the atreides
sleeping pills to make their capture a
bit more easy this doesn't happen in
lynches dr yui's wife is apparently
still alive in the 2021 version and he
uses this betrayal to get her back in
1984 yui believes his wife is already
dead and this is just a ploy with this
whole poison 2 thing to get revenge the
1984 version has almost no close
quarters combat but we get lots here in
vil news with the sardikar even
utilizing these samurai-like swords it's
in this attack that duncan idaho is
killed in the 1984 version whereas
villeneuve saves his death for later on
jessica and paul's escape from the
harkonnen is pretty close to 84s but
after they land things change quite
drastically in lynch's version they are
quickly united with stilgar and the
fremen but villeneuve decides to have
them team up with kinds and take shelter
at a nearby ecological station it's here
that duncan idaho has his last stand
believe it or not we never see the baron
eat in the 1984 version but we do in
2021's poison tooth scene in 84 lato
hallucinates and breaks the tooth in
pider's face not the baron the baron
comes out pretty much uninjured here
whereas in the 2021 version it has him
recuperating for weeks in this black goo
i'm curious if this black goo is related
to that stuff that comes out of the baby
sandworms that we see later in the 1984
version perhaps it has some healing
property like duncan kynes is also given
way more screen time here she helps
usher paul and jessica to the fremen and
even dies in the process doing so she
calls forth a sand worm using a thumper
and looks as though she's preparing to
ride one before she is slaughtered by
the sarda car not seen in the 84 version
is paul's vision of him fighting
alongside the fremen against the sardar
car with these blue eyes this hints at
events in part 2 where he'll take on the
harkonnen and emperor it's easy to miss
but you can also see a sand worm in the
back in both versions paul and the
frerman control the worms in their
battle against the oppressors i should
also mention the books that kines is
cheney's father so not exactly sure how
this will play out going forward doom
2021 also does a better job at
foreshadowing events beyond dune itself
paul has a nightmare vision about a
warrior religion that waves the atreides
banner in his father's name this is
pointing to events in dune messiah and
children of dune and who knows if dune
is wildly successful there are plenty of
more books to mine material from there's
also this ecological station where kinds
talks about a process that could turn
the sands of dune into a lush green
paradise when paul becomes emperor he'll
start this process paul and the others
talk about how the attack on house of
tradies may cause an all-out war between
the emperor and various houses of the
landsrod but now that the emperor and
harkonnen control the spice such a war
would be very difficult to avoid a war
of this scale paul suggests he could
marry one of the emperor's daughters
since the emperor has no male heirs it's
a wild idea that is quickly brushed
aside but one that foreshadows paul
eventually marrying princess ireland the
emperor's daughter if you haven't seen
my children of dune video i go into that
in more depth i also love the scene
where duncan idaho bows to paul as the
new duke not seen in 84 it's a very
small scene but it carries a lot of
weight there's no such sandstorm copter
chase in 1984 a chase which lands them
in the far reaches of arrakis where
they're chased off by a sand worm i'll
go into more detail in my ending
explained about this scene but man it
really seemed like this worm was
laughing at him
what are you laughing at me for
something not seen in the 1984 version
is the bene gesture at sign language
which paul and jessica used to secretly
communicate this is however used in
children of dune between iran and the
reverend mother eventually paul and
jessica stumble upon a foreman tribe led
by stilgar there's no real fight here
between jessica and stilgar like we see
in the 2021 version she merely takes
stillgaard by the throat which prompts
james to invoke the amtol rule a fight
to the death it's also here that paul is
introduced to cheney the woman from his
dreams and she thinks he's going to get
his ass kicked in this fight paul ends
up killing james even after sparing him
three times with paul victorious the
2021 version ends with paul deciding to
stay on arrakis and fight the emperor
and hearken him if you're curious what
happens next check out my dune 1984
video which covers the events likely to
be seen in dune part 2. there you have
it some of the major differences between
the two dunes i hope you enjoyed the
video be sure to like subscribe and i
have a whole other playlist with other
cool comparison videos thanks for
watching and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much